okay it's a pleasure to introduce the
second speaker this afternoon also is my
colleague at Cornell synergy postdoc at
Stanford I guess me a PI here doing here
but maybe recently is coming more often
and I guess he's at Cornell he is also
going to be a long-term visitor of this
program work is about the visitor of
this program going to really be
long-term here in the second half of the
semester and to speak great thank you
okay perfect
um okay so thank you very much for the
invitation so I'm going to sort of be
doing the third piece of this talk and
societal networks on ride-sharing the
stocks gonna be a little different from
the previous two in that it'll be less
focused on the data but much more on
just what are the problems in the space
of ride-sharing what how how we can
model these or at least how people have
been working with have been modeling
these there are various models for this
and we can discuss that somewhat um what
how where we are in terms of solving the
algorithmic questions but in some sense
there's a lot of open questions in this
field and I'm looking forward to working
with many of you during the semester and
hopefully think about some of these um
the reason I put up these three are the
pictures is these were my collaborators
on this project but also their long-term
visitors for this workshop so Romeo Hari
who was also my postdoc advisor at
Stanford Daniel friend is not here today
but he will be around soon you've
already seen some pictures of him and
David stock today is Lee Curtis is
sitting back there
please direct all the really difficult
technical questions in his direction and
this will also work done with Carlos
Academy who was a student at Stanford
when I was doing a postdoc there but
just a little bit about the genesis the
genesis of how I even started thinking
about these problems so while I was at
Stanford doing a postdoc
we started thinking a bit about problems
in dynamic pricing with respect to right
and the sort of serendipitous be we
happen to talk to some folks at lyft
actually Chris Shirley who still getting
coffee or no he's right over there
um well sort of really nice enough to
invite us over to live to talk about
some of our ideas and it turned out that
the folks in the data science team at
lyft were also just starting to
experiment with dynamic pricing and
we're trying to figure out okay how how
should we go about this and I spent I
think four to five really really fun
months working as a consultant uplift
this is back in 2014 and the early days
of dynamic pricing and in fact Daniel
was also there over the summer some of
these flights that I'd show are actually
taken from the lyft recruiting slides
and if anyone is interested in problems
with ride-sharing please get in touch
with Chris I hear they're looking for
lots of people to work on these problems
and I can assure you it's a lot of fun
okay so what am I going to be talking
about once I get this one
so this talk is pretty much entirely on
right sharing um some of what I will
talk about will apply in general to
vehicle sharing problems so including
bike sharing but there are certain
features of ride sharing which makes it
special and interesting they are
increasingly becoming critical
components of urban transit when I used
to give this talk two years back I'd
still explain what lyft and uber is some
people hadn't heard about it and it's
nice that as time goes on my intro
slides can get shorter and I can talk
more about everything else the reason I
find it really interesting is I think
ride-sharing platforms are truly a
crucible for sort of the set of problems
that I think about and many of us here
think about in in real time
decision-making in operations management
in general but also in sort of
algorithmic economics so there are
aspects of like when I teach courses on
pricing or on market design I often find
for most of the concepts that I am
trying to teach ride-sharing is a great
example at some point I have to stop
myself from using it as an example but
then the nice thing is because these
platforms are pretty much coming up from
scratch you can a lot of it as an
explorer and you can go in and actually
try some ideas and with a fairly short
turnaround time get these things
implemented so there's an amazing
laboratory for people working in these
these areas to try out the theory in
practice I will still give a brief
overview just in case there are some
people who haven't used it so what is a
ride-sharing service it's essentially a
paired set of apps there's one up for
drivers one up for passengers this is
what you see as a passenger you sort of
go into the app you see a bunch of
vehicles moving around you request a
ride there are a bunch of different
modes you can request it in you can
request a shared right or a right on
your own on a bigger vehicle once you
request it you get much to someone and
you get shown a price I'll talk more
about this later but essentially get
much to a person you enter your
destination the person gives you a ride
you get dropped off you pay through the
app the entire experience is sort of
mediated through the app you give
feedback or actually both parties give
feedback to each other and that sort of
completes the ride so
I mean it's a very critical piece in the
whole thing and perhaps the piece which
gets the most attention at least in the
press is how these platforms do pricing
in particular how they do dynamic
pricing this used to be different
earlier so earlier what used to happen
is you never actually found out the
price you could get a price estimate
with what you did find was this notion
of the price multiplier the way it works
now both in lyft and uber is what you is
what's called upfront pricing and the
idea is that when you go into the app
you see an indicator of what's the
current primetime or surge level so here
it says that right now if you take a
ride you're gonna pay 25% extra if you
choose to take a ride but at the moment
you enter your destination and actually
so even before you request a ride you
are given a price up front so you're
given a price you can decide at that
moment whether or not you paid and once
you decide that that's it the price does
not change you could get stuck in
traffic etc etc the price is not
adjusted there's some caveats to this
there certain other modes of working if
you take a bull ride etc but essentially
this is how the models work today
testing the notion of what about sharing
now means in this situation to what
extent in terms of numbers are how do
the numbers of user of riders and cart
providers compare and is there fluid
flow between those those two classes of
participants or or is it as a see so
okay providers good so that I genuinely
don't know we do have folks from lyft
and actually folks from over as well and
I have not directly worked on the data
at least far um yeah I think I'll leave
it at that so I'll talk much more about
from a modeling perspective whether the
fluid versus the discrete matters but in
terms of what it is on the ground
there's a sense of symmetry of right
user and right provider are those fixed
roles no I'm pretty soaking I'm pretty
sure those change so you do have people
who are both users and drivers and one
way you actually see this a lot is there
are you do see people switching back and
forth between the apps maybe to see the
prices etcetera etcetera so they do so
one thing people often ask about is okay
what if you don't show the prices to the
drivers will they ever find out but then
most people can switch to the passenger
mode and see the prices so yes so that
there are I don't know numbers on this
but I'm pretty sure there are people who
use it in both modes not simultaneously
but so and just to sort of complete the
story on what prime time or this dynamic
pricing looks like um as of now and I
believe this may or may not be changing
but as of now the prices for a ride are
based on distance at time so there's a
fixed multiplier for distance and time
there are some additional fees for
insurance etc but what you actually pay
is the price based on distance and time
multiplied by the surge multiplier so
this is what a receipt from lyft look
like this is actually quite old by now
this two or three years back now it's a
little more complicated but at the heart
of it this is the structure so this was
someone taking a ride on January 31st at
12:35 a.m. got a 25% primetime I would
actually say he got lucky okay so what
are in some sense the space of problems
in a rideshare system um I'm going to
kind of break it up into three separate
pieces of one large space of real-time
decision making problems are concerned
with mapping so these ride-sharing
systems have a huge amount of data from
the GPS of the cars and they're using it
to sort of get better at the estimates
of trying to estimate people's locations
better and better these things are
actually really important for things
like building purposes for example you
need to estimate the distances
accurately if you are building correctly
and so all right sharing
firms have a large team working on
problems related to map
the doors are problems I'm more
interested in uh firstly problems
related to logistics so what I mean by
this is this is so if the logistics in
terms of the supply once you've already
accepted the demand so once you have
committed to giving a right to a person
you need to decide which car to dispatch
so here I'm kind of showing up
hypothetical example where there are two
riders who are asking for rides and
there's three cars and you're trying to
decide okay who should go to whom and
the idea perhaps would be that by
marching one driver to one passenger
you're sort of preserving drivers for
perhaps more busy location so you want
to think about how to optimize these
dispatch decisions when asked once
you've accepted it right you can also
think about matching so this is more to
do with the right pooling side of it so
both lyft and uber have a service where
you can share a ride with one or more
person and in order to figure out what's
the best way to sort of take the
portfolio of rights that you have and
match it up to people asking for it it's
it's a non-trivial combinatorial problem
and you need to do this really fast
because someone asks for a read you need
to decide very quickly who should they
be matched I perhaps the piece of it
which captivates most people are at
least which for me is most interesting
is that even outside all the logistical
problems in these systems at the heart
of it ride-sharing systems are
marketplaces so they don't at the moment
they don't have any drivers as employees
they don't as far as we know have too
many autonomous vehicles so at the
moment the rides the supply is being
provided by freelance drivers who are
choosing whether or not they want to
work on the platform and what lyft and
uber doing is they're not sort of
actually sort of taking some supply and
matching it to demand they're setting up
the rules of a marketplace so they they
are kind of think of it as they're
writing this notice saying this is what
would happen if you join the market as a
driver or a passenger and then
everyone's making a decision whether or
not it works for them and there are
various ways in which this shows up that
- a really interesting problem that
piece for me is firstly primetime
pricing how do you do dynamic
state-dependent pricing in a
ride-sharing system
and this is paja is much more visible to
most people what is also more
interesting what is also equally
interesting but perhaps less visible is
what are the levers you use to
incentivize drivers so how do you serve
incentivizes them to drive at certain
hours how do you incentivize them to
drive at certain locations etc etc and
what this talk is going to be about is
essentially these two pieces so how do
how do we formally model and think about
logistics and market design what are the
algorithmic challenges what do we know
where do we want to go another was
saying there's a kind of bigger
ecosystem of on-demand transportation
which ride-sharing is a particular part
of so we already heard they were talking
about bike sharing and there also some
services where like car to go or zip car
where essentially you have shared cars
which without drivers you have the cars
parked at various locations in the city
and you can rent these cars for a
certain amount of time so they're a more
on-demand version of essentially a car
rental service and what's common across
all of these modes of transportation in
some sense are that they all have really
fast operational time scale so the
number of rides per minute is much
larger than like if you think of let's
say an airplane pricing system in the
number of people looking for us tickets
for a single airplane versus say
ride-sharing system they're the order of
magnitude difference in volume but also
what's really interesting about these
systems is that they have very complex
network externalities so what I mean by
that is unlike in others of system
comparable systems in a ride-sharing
system if you take a ride from one
location to another you've changed the
supply of the source location you've
also changed the supply at some future
time at the destination location so you
start up by taking one ride you've
you've affected the network at various
points and these sort of effects
propagate through and so when you are
trying to think about how to control
these systems you have to think about
these propagating effects so to some
extent you should think about these
propagating effects and how much that
effects your policies they're also very
different control leavers than what we
had before dynamic pricing as before but
also how you can change dispatch based
on current information
how you change incentives in a dynamic
fashion how you can pool demand together
etc and there are newer challenges
coming up so as ride-sharing becomes
more and more prevalent and people start
accepting it we need to start thinking
about things like competition so how
does it matter that we have multiple
rideshare providers how how are they
interacting with each other what's the
effect of that on society one thing
which at least for me is really
important is what is the effect of these
systems on public transit so I'm right
sharing systems so if claim that they
want to make transportation as cheap as
water but there is a feeling that they
should there must be effects of that on
public transit and gentlemen can we
start sort of formally trying to
understand what these effects and what
are the synergies between these systems
and kind of even more generally what's
the effect of having these systems are
now been planning in general no I'm not
going to try to solve any of these
problems but sort of try to outline what
I think are ways in which we can start
thinking more so what is this talk about
so what I am going to talk about is a
simple framework for trying to formalize
these questions so what is a simple
modeling framework for formalizing
dispatch pricing rebalancing in a
ride-sharing system how does it
incorporate things like data state and
controls and once we have that what
we've been working on right now is
firstly how do you do approximate
optimal control in these so the
underlying control problems are highly
non convex and high dimensional but we
have some ideas now and how do you do
this well in in certain approximate
senses and then secondly and this was
the work I originally started off with
what is the effect of what is the role
of dynamic pricing in the system and
kind of more generally what is the role
of market mechanism in a ride-sharing
system and my view of it is that the
main or perhaps the most important
contribution of a market mechanism in
the system is that it's a tool
essentially for what I call algorithmic
self calibration so although these
systems are trying to learn demand and
supplies there are certain barriers to
doing that and having these dynamic
market mechanisms allows you to get over
these barriers and then I try to kind of
conclude with some questions which I
think are of in
but you know I'd be interested in
hearing what other state okay so the
main challenge in any ride-sharing or
any vehicle sharing system kind of if I
wanted to boil it down to one word it is
rebalancing so any of these systems by
virtue of being on demand they have
non-uniform demand and supply across
space and time and you need some way of
aligning the demand and supply in space
and time and there are kind of two
high-level ways of doing it so there is
a sort of logistical solution which is
you try to rebalance this fleet and
David talked a lot about how that's done
and bike sharing systems I actually took
that diagram from Daniel's website this
is the of the demand supply imbalances
at a certain time in the city bike
system and you can see something similar
so this is actually a video of this car
to go system I think this is in Los
Angeles and what you can see is for some
reason the video is not working but what
happens in this video is as the day goes
on you can see the car sort of gravitate
towards the downtown early in the
morning and then they get stuck there
and car to go and zip car actually have
a car to go because they don't have
fixed parking spots they actually have
people who manually go and drive these
cars back and David again talked about
like the incentives for doing that now
the second thing is this of economic
solution so the incentives for moving
these cars from the point of view of
passengers but also in the case of
ride-sharing incentives for drivers
incentives so main driver sort of join
the platform at certain times a worker
in certain locations and then many
control levers for doing this
rebalancing so pricing is the obvious
one I already talked a bit about
dispatch but increasingly people are
thinking about how if you had empty
vehicles in the network how you would
rebalance
there are certain ways of doing this by
nudging the driver so drivers get to see
what are called heat maps in some sense
an idea of where the demand profile is
something which looks like that and they
can self choose where they want to work
but increasingly as autonomous vehicles
come into the mix there's a possibility
that you can genuinely control some of
these vehicles and use these forty
buttons
so so that's sort of the problem space
that I want to look at and so what I'll
talk about in maybe the next 10 minutes
is in a simple model which captures most
of these effects it doesn't capture
everything and at the end of it we can
stop and sort of think a bit about
what's in and what's not in the model
before going on to so here's kind of my
like really simplistic way of thinking
about what a ride-sharing platform is
and essentially I'm viewing it as what's
called a closed queuing network in
stochastic modeling so what's happening
over here what I'm trying to depict is
here's a network where you're four
stations so think of these stations as
localities in a city and each of these
stations have a number of vehicles so
these are vehicles which are located in
that same neighborhood at this current
instant of time so in this case you have
four neighborhoods you have two vehicles
here three over here one over here I'm
going to assume throughout that there
are n stations and the total number of
vehicles is M and this is remaining
fixed or the fixed number of vehicles
which are so distributed across this
network so any instant of time the state
of the system is basically a point in
this nm simplex it's a distribution of M
vehicles amongst n locations and what
I'm going to assume is that you have a
stochastic stream of passengers arriving
at different locations in the network
and in particular the rate at which
passengers show up at location I and
want to go to location J is given by a
Poisson process with rate CIJ more about
this later but for the time being so
there is sort of a matrix of these
arrival rates and at each node you have
these different Poisson flows coming in
and wanting to go to different
destinations
so what I've drawn over here in the
dashed line is basically a passenger who
showed up at this location who wants to
go over here and now the platform needs
to decide whether or not it wants to
serve this passenger and at what price
they should do so so what the platform
gets to do is they get to set state
dependent prices so what do I mean by
this the platform can look at the system
and go okay I have so many vehicles here
here and here
based on this I feel you should pay so
much for the right and so this price is
offered to the passenger in the form of
this upfront price and then the
passenger I'm assuming is sort of making
an instantaneous decision if they feel
the price is good enough they take the
right so each passenger has some value
for the ride it's drawn from some
distribution if they are in the tail of
the distribution of the value is more
than the price they're willing to take
the right so what happens once the
passengers matched up is the car starts
moving this typically will take some
time to go from one location to another
for simplicity in this talk I'm going to
assume the travel times are zero this is
not critical so here I have so what
happened here is we went from three cars
over here to three cars in that location
another passenger showed up there is a
car available willing to pay the price
the car moves so what happens if the car
is not available and I'm going to make
an assumption that the customers are
myopic so what I mean by that is if
someone shows up and they see that there
is no vehicle available within a
reasonable ETA they just abandon the
system so maybe maybe they switch the
app or they take public transit they
take a bike etcetera but from the point
of this point of view of the platform
they drop out so that's one way in which
you can have customers abandoning the
other way in which a customer can
abandon is if you offer a price and the
customer decides it's too high it's not
too cold i'ma try the bike
so that then uh pretty much entirely
encapsulate the system if you think
you've had some prior exposure to
thinking about stochastic models um just
knowing which vehicle is located well is
actually a complete description you can
figure out the entire Markov chain of
the entire evolution of the system based
on that information and the objective
that we are concerned with is optimizing
some sort of long-run average system
objective so it's not obvious what is
the target objective of this platform so
the platform's do care about revenue for
sure but then given that they're just in
some sense they're still sort of gaining
traction and they want people to use it
the platform's definitely care about
customer engagement how many rights
they're giving and in some global sense
the ride-sharing platforms also care
about our people happy using the using
the system so what is the overall
welfare of both the drivers and the
passengers in the system but what I'm
interested in is you give me a choice of
objective it may be a combination of
these I want to come up with an
algorithm which sets these prices to
optimize the long-run average of the
subject
yes that's pretty much the entire model
posit any questions clarifications yeah
maybe that the way you deal with space
so you have these four locations it
seems like you've discretized space yeah
I have okay that's a great point so yeah
I have so I am assuming the the network
is partition into these discrete chunks
but you're right in asking why did I
assume that this person couldn't get a
right maybe that place was near enough
um so actually that's a good place to
sort of start thinking about okay what
are the control levers I have in some
sense what I talked up till now was just
about pricing so I can deter or
encourage people to go from one place to
another just by increasing or decreasing
the prices so what I'm indicating over
here is in some sense if I know that
there's a unavailability of vehicles in
these two nodes and there's excess over
here I should try and set up flows which
go from like excess to deficit by
adjusting the prices and that's kind of
the main control lever we'll be thinking
about but another very natural control
lever is if there is unavailability you
can ask the question maybe I can pull
vehicles from somewhere else and this is
what is typically called the dispatch
problem and in general the dispatch
problem is more general so if I have a
passenger who's shown up who wants to go
to some location given a set of vehicles
within certain of ETA budget or I want
to decide which one to pull and it may
be that when I pull one of these
vehicles because it's too far away the
passenger may about them so that's the
serve that's another control leaver
which is actually after the prices once
once the passengers accepted the prices
I need to decide or I need to empower
and decide the dispatch the other thing
you can model using remotes the same set
up is how would you rebalance empty
vehicles so in this setting suppose I
don't want to think as much about the
pricing on the dispatch but what I
really want to do is whenever I have
vehicle whenever I have unavailability I
want to take vehicles from an overloaded
location and ask them to move as I said
the ways of doing this using nudges but
I mean in future this could be an
autonomous vehicle moving the point of
course is in order to do so
to incur cost I mean there's a vehicle
driving and I incur the cost of the
miles um and something I want to use
this model to think about all of these
problems question it good clarity you
mentioned this a single price how does
that work with the notion of this is
platform for our market or our markets
that brings together willing sellers and
willing purchases to prices and spread
so what does the driver see yeah good um
so I'll actually talk more about the
drivers in the second part of the talk
the short answer as of now I'm correct
me if I'm wrong the driver usually gets
a fixed percentage of the price charged
to the passenger um there's no
underlying economic reason for doing
that um it's arguably you should have a
spread from what I understand there may
be partially legal reasons for sort of
having this kind of linear structure so
right now it is if you give a ride you
get 80 percent or 75 percent of whatever
the passenger pays there are exceptions
to this um the notable one is in right
pooling so if you take say lyft line
right yep you're getting a discount
because there's a there's a thought that
you may be encouraging sharing down the
line and what happens at least in the
case of lyft is lift is sort of taking
the risk upon themselves so that the
driver is getting paid as if it was a
single trade whereas the passengers are
paying a different amount and the hope
and sort of the Delta is being taken up
by the platform but we'll come back to
the pricing in more detail later right
so the first part of the talk will
assume these vehicles are sort of given
it's like fixed supply the major the
most of the kind of the non-trivial part
here is that the supply is spread around
the network and we need to move it so
it's purely logistical problem
here the questions okay so yes I've been
somewhat clearer it's late in the day so
usually I get a lot of criticism at this
point about the model I'm going to try
and attack someone try and answer some
of these criticisms early on while
admitting that there are things which
are definitely outside the moment so so
firstly okay why even do this why even
do theoretical models we have these
amazing systems they have excellent of
experimental infrastructures why not
just just try out different policies all
the time and until an extent that is
done there's a huge amount of a/b
testing which has been done by all of
these platforms but I would still argue
that there's a huge amount of value in
doing this kind of like formal modeling
of these systems so one of them is that
the soft scales and the real-time nature
of these systems essentially mean that
you must have very very simple
algorithms so you can't be running
something which is extremely complicated
in the backend while simultaneously
pricing like every minute for every
location across an entire city it's just
not going to scale up and so even if you
think that there are complex controls
which have a huge benefit these need
more resources and you in some sense
should be arguing is the gain
commensurate so you need way more
manpower to implement these systems you
need many more machines you need better
sort of like better communications is it
worth the gains that you get that sort
of a crucial question most of these that
theory with hopes to answer there's also
the problem that in even though these
these companies have excellent data
science teams um then in some sense
there is always going to be some error
in your estimation and forecasting and
you're then using this these erroneous
estimates and forecasts back in your
model and claiming its optimal man
should be worried about okay how how are
they there are sort of propagating
through and there are certain things
which are just very very difficult to
learn so how do you learn what is a
passengers willingness to pay if you can
only show like a fixed set of prices or
if you don't want to experiment on
passengers which for it's unclear the
forms are actually doing price
experimentation but even just given that
you have like five or six prices how do
you
Demond curves very well and demand
curves are easier to learn how exactly
do you learn a supply curve how do you
figure out why a driver is willing to
work for certain house afford a that
there also have long-term effects in
this which are just very difficult to
try and extract from it so our forums
are thinking of as known unknown then in
some sense having these models gives you
a sense of how how susceptible are you
to these errors or Holocaust or instance
and then beyond all of this there are
sort of things which we just don't know
about these systems are extremely new
and they have certain effects on people
which in some senses outside the
modeling framework and by being hyper
aggressive about how we sort of control
these systems you may have certain side
impacts which you wouldn't account for
now I don't mean to sort of try and jump
on new bird and suggest that your delete
over so this was an issue close to a
year back when there was a there was a
strike in JFK Airport and uber at some
point actually decided that they from
what I understand they realized that
there was such pricing and they realized
that this was not a this was not
desirable because it was in reaction to
a strike and they actually turned it off
and announced that it's being turned off
but interestingly evolved from what I
understand this was perceived as being
anti strike because by saying that you
turned it off you someone suggested you
against the strike I'm not going to take
a side in this as someone who's actually
helped design these of dynamic pricing
systems um there's a sense that these
sort of problems can happen and you need
to be careful or you need to have simple
systems which you can understand and you
know what these effects are because else
you may kind of get into these unknown
so like you what is you really need to
understand what is the value of even
just doing dynamic pricing because you
know people are getting upset about this
is more like first of all you're running
or a day when this is
and then are you taking the surge
pricing off make it look like no I mean
I totally see the optics yeah but
there's a sense that yeah which
assumption in our model captured these
optics for which an option like these
are really tough to think about and in
some sense if you have simpler models
and algorithms you have some sense that
I think this could still happen but
maybe you have some control over it
sorry so that's that's why I think it's
mean it's still despite all the a/b
testing and despite having this of
excellence of experimentation and
infrastructure it's still useful to sort
of come up think about like formal
models for this and why this particular
model why the stochastics now we want to
think about that I'm just gonna sort of
go through what I think are the crucial
assumptions and there's a sense that
none of these hold completely but we do
understand to some sense in some sense
how much I results depend upon these so
the first thing that I'm assuming is
that there is what I think of as a time
scale of practice from operations so
there's some amount of time within which
the number of cars the arrival rates the
elasticity is all of these remain
constant so maybe there's the morning
Russia
we already saw these plots from David
about the bike sharing system where it
was clear that this is not true um
so there are definitely self
time-varying behavior throughout the day
and it's an interesting question as to
what's the effect of this in practice
what you can do is you can take whatever
policies we suggest and resolve this
whenever you think things have changed
but we have some thoughts about how our
guarantees would change but in general
that's an open question what happens
when you have time varying rates I'm
assuming that the number of cars so you
know the number of vehicles with
customers so customers was a Poisson
flow of cost yeah so okay
so unclear so if the flow of pathogens
given I'm unclear what the manulis
so many passenger shows up we can offer
them a price and they are showing up in
itself we depend upon the price no
because you can see if someone opened
their app to look for a right before
this Idol price but if I know that the
uber price is gonna be half of what it
was yesterday I'm much more likely to
open my app ok that's completely fair so
I think maybe what you're pointing out
is that there is a longer term entry
decision yeah so right exactly so one
example I knew of this was near this
person at Stanford who we used to go to
Stanford from the city and at some point
of time he needed to make a decision of
whether he would take his bike to the
station or whether he would take in this
case ok this was someone who thought a
lot about experimentation so he
experimented he sort of tried it for a
month and saw how much it cost him
despite the price fluctuations but yes
um that is one of the long-term effects
which I think are just very difficult to
capture and in some sense what I want to
do is convince you that like dynamic
pricing is so essential that we are
willing to incur that risk
so the point but I know there's paper
from Chicago which claim that Cooper's
welfare benefit was 12 billion dollars
because it took was very short term
elasticity and that was a long term
elasticity right what does that decide
to take Cooper I'm going to pay 50% more
land than otherwise all right completely
so so I'm assuming that there's a big
answer that in some sense the friction
of checking your app is so small that
before you head out of your home just
check your app maybe it's not expensive
but I completely agree there long-term
effects which in some sense I'm ok
getting out of the violence um the dots
of this okay in some sense the model I
talked about with the persona rivals it
doesn't talk about bus so if if you are
at a the 4th Street Station in the
morning and our train just arrived do
you have a bunch of people coming off
you're not coming on in this night's
Poisson manner and then
thing people in stochastic control
really like thinking about what is the
effect of this was the right way of
pricing against it I'm not going to talk
about that in this time the second sort
of time scale separation that I'm
assuming is in that of strategic
interaction so what I mean by this is I
already mentioned that I'm thinking of
the passengers has been completely
myopic so they come in they look at the
system if there is no availability if
there's no availability they leave if
the price is too high they leave there's
not they're not waiting around they're
not sort of playing game saying oh I'm
going to look at it for five minutes and
decide etcetera etcetera so they just
leave instantaneously the other hand I'm
actually going to later on write off
what pricing I'm going to assume that
the drivers are reacting at a very
different time scale so they sort of
sampling the system for a much larger
amount of time and deciding whether or
not it's worthwhile for them to work on
the system owner so there is this have
intrinsic separation in the time scale
some of this you can see from the data
but in some sense this I'm going to take
as a given the thing which I feel is
most troublesome about the way I set it
up is I'm assuming a lot about the
availability of data so I'm assuming
that you have perfect knowledge of the
arrival written praveen's pointing out
correctly um I'm assuming a lot about
knowing about the demand elasticity's
and maybe I'm getting this completely
wrong it's difficult to learn maybe this
is changing over time so is it really
true that I have this information I'm
sort of more subtly is it really needed
to have all of this information or can
my policy sort of do well enough without
this information yeah you're still with
the notion of just a clock ticket not
metric clock ticking um so money I'm
assuming everything's and continuously
so it's a continuous time Markov chain
so yeah continuous time discrete space
okay so this is kind of the first piece
of what we can do with this model um
this is joint work with other listen
Daniel on like how do we think about
like optimizing the logistics in these
systems and just to repr recap what was
going on I had a somewhat messy diagram
but just bear with me so I have these
flows of passengers these Poisson rates
sure enough I offer each person a price
the price could be sort of origin
destination dependent it could depend on
the state of the system based on the
price the flow gets thin down to some
extent and then all of these people show
up looking for a ride
and I have these M vehicles at different
points and there's this a flow of cars
in the network which is set up due to
this due to the prices and I want to try
and understand once I saw a fixed
pricing policy I want to understand how
what how my a certain objective behaves
in steady-state so why is this difficult
try to sort of walk you through so just
what is complex about even thinking
about this so so what I really want to
do is I want to select as a thinning
parameter for each pair of nodes so for
people going from I to J I want to
decide what fraction of them to admit by
choosing a price and I can choose this
as a function of the state of the system
so for every instantaneous state I can
choose as a collection of prices and
these prices are going to induce some
sort of long term like some sort of
Markov chain in the system and I want to
try and maximize the expected reward
added up over all pairs of origin
destinations under this induced measure
so so that's the problem I'm trying to
look at an and this expected reward
itself is not very nice it's kind of
broken up into a bunch of parts so
firstly I have to ensure that there's
availability if there's no vehicle there
I can't give a ride this is the rate at
which the people showing up wanting to
go from idle J Sophie C IJ is this
underlying rate and then I've pinned it
down by choosing a price and then once
both of these are met I'm giving a ride
I get some expected reward from
trait and I'm denoting that as this
function I so this is the expected
reward I get if I someone actually takes
a right to go from A to G and I'm going
to assume Q is that's actually my
control so I'm choosing a price and the
price induces so for every state I say
okay I'm going to let in so right now
there's so many vehicles I build of X
the instantaneous fraction of people I
don't yeah so there's one thing I've
swept a bit under the carpet here is
instead of thinking about prices I'm
thinking about how many what fraction I
admit but it's a one-to-one relation and
I'm going to assume that this this
function Q times I of Q is concave and Q
this is not a very severe assumption
this actually turns out to be true for a
lot of objectives you'd like to think
about so it's true for just the rate at
which you give rides in the system is a
volume of right it's true if you just
look at the economic welfare it's true
for the revenue function under certain
regularity assumption of these capital
maps so for many objectives that we care
about we know that Q times I have Q is
concave but this is still a really
really ugly optimization problem so
firstly I'm going to serve go back to
the simpler notation but no matter what
I do no matter how I dress it up it's
still the policy that I am trying to
choose this exponential size so for
every possible state of a occurs in the
system I need to choose this matrix of
crisis so the hugely policy space it
turns out that even if you sort of
drastically reduce the policy space so
even if you say I'm not going to look at
the state I will just have a fixed price
for a free origin destination fare now
you're just looking at n square
parameters but even then this problem is
non convex and it turns out to be non
convex and so really really simple
instance of this like three stations and
one bike so what really tend to solve is
something which is non convex under and
choose an exponential size policy we
initially didn't think there was much
hope of doing this
then surprisingly turns out that you can
actually come up with a very interesting
sort of approximate control policy for
so in particular you can what we showed
was that there's a convex relaxation for
this problem which gives state
independent prices so it's a much
smaller space of prices that has to be
true if we wanted to be computationally
feasible so and these state independent
prices give us an approximation factor
which is roughly 1 plus number of
stations divided by number of angles so
no matter what the optimal policy is we
have something which will give us a
guarantee of 1 plus n minus 1 over m so
stadium demand just means in at every
station fine when some passage arrives
with J no matter whether because if
there's no vehicle I quote the price but
I'll say sorry there's no very good if
there is a very fixed price right and
but there's no rebuttal the drivers
don't get any and the moment is yeah I'm
not considering rebalancing question so
you set that up check the function is
concave now I just said this piece q
times I of cuba's concave but the
problem is this indicator over here
actually breaks down the concavity so
now like that I need to condition on on
availability actually breaks the
concavity and I like question sir
and that performance guarantee is number
of stations yeah so I believe um I don't
know what would happen if you did finer
and finer partitions which is what I
think you're going I think that's an
interesting open question like what is
the right granularity of doing the
prices in practice we saw the picture
earlier the ratio there is a certain
granularities which is chosen for just
engineering reasons but it's unclear if
that's the optimal graph I think that's
a great question I mean it but if you
take that 3 ratio to be
and then let the number where you can
scale yeah so what I think is nice about
this is that is the right sense of karma
transition so it's sort of intuitively
capturing the fact that as I have more
and more supply I get closer to optimal
so it's it's stronger than just saying
this is to approximate or something it's
saying that in a natural sense as I
increase the number of acres the number
of stations most probably doesn't change
to actually gets better um there's also
an interesting thing which is not
obvious in this but if you scale both
the demand and the supply so if you look
at a serf conventional fluid limit of
the system you can still show this
approximation factor goes to one this
was not known for this system so even a
fluid optimal policy was not known for a
closed queuing system until a recent
result of Jim delaying but in some sense
we get a elementary proof of that fact
without constructing a fluid complete
aside but but there is this a very
strong sense in which this is really the
nicest approximation this is does this
suggest that because I mean this
constants you know as we had in the
previous book you so get periodic yeah
doesn't come about so imagine our view
in a few minutes that so it's definitely
true that the time varying nature
affects things I do think a lot of if
you you can get some sort of weaker
guarantees under this these policies but
in some sense I think this is the right
style of policy even if you have time
varying so what you do is you resolve
often enough I would argue that the
bigger problem is that these policies
need to know all these parameters which
are just much harder I think that's the
fundamental bottleneck and that's what I
think pricing itself but yeah to our
guarantee is extend to dynamic or to
time varying arrivals
there's some gap why don't you brief
cent oh sorry if there's a question
I have a flat price for origin
destination prepared during a period of
time when everything remains constant if
my demand changes I'll change the price
in some sense if you really believe that
demand stay fixed on average for a
three-hour block I'll have the same
price and then the next three are long I
will change the price within that block
yes it's a flat place I've come back in
a bit towards the end about what you can
do with state-dependent but it's even
surprising for us like there's a some
non trivial existence result here that
that's such a good policy even exists
with state independent works that wasn't
obvious to us when we started okay so
how do we prove something like this just
just very briefly um so what we did was
essentially we came up with this idea of
what we call the elevated through
relaxation and it's essentially a convex
program for that problem which gives a
valid upper bound um while encoding
certain conservation now so if anyone
has seen things like self airline
pricing this is similar to looking at a
fluid model of the problem but with some
subtle differences so the non-trivial
part and I'll talk briefly about this
but the non-trivial part is to try and
connect this relaxation to the problem
with like to the actual problem and what
we can do is can do this in two steps so
we take this relaxation and then we say
imagine a world where we had infinite
vehicles and then show something about
like the tightness of the of these
policies in the infinite banking system
and then we argue how much do you lose
for every vehicle that you do what is
the gain per vehicle that you get and by
self combining these beings and the fact
that there is an upper bound assurance
now so what is this flow relaxation and
I would argue the flu if you think a
little about it
this is sort of natural although it took
us a long time to view it this way so
what's going on is I'm trying to choose
some set of cues from set up like
admission rates as a function of the
current state in order to maximize this
ugly looking thing but I've already
argued that this Q times I of Q is
concave so some of concave functions
this
now suppose some Oracle came and told us
hey this is the optimal queue story and
in particular this is the optimal sort
of average admission rate between i2j
the vector of average admission rates
for this entire system what I know from
Jensen's inequality is if I just sort of
put in the average admission rates then
I get about it up the wall there's
nothing so fancy if you just look at the
fact that this is concave and somebody
told me the optimal solution I know I
have an upper bound and now I can say
well instead of doing this I could just
maximize over all sort of vectors of
admission rates and the nice thing is
this is a concave program it's just a
maximization over a bunch of some of
concave functions now this turns out to
be two weeks okay there's a convex
program because it's a maximization of
concave objective what sort of magical
is that you can then add a bunch of
additional constraints in particular you
can add these sort of what we called
circulation constraints and something
which encodes littles law and show that
once you add in these constraints these
are just linear constraints then you get
a convex relaxation which actually gives
you that current and this step is our
non-trivial but it's kind of clear that
this is the natural relaxation that you
do for this problem but you kind of need
it to do this weird go to infinity and
back to show that this one's not going
to go into more detail but sort of if
you combine the the short thing that I
want you to say that this is really the
natural convex relaxation that you would
consider you would just try to maximize
overall admission rates while ignoring
the fact that there are these weird
cross linkages ignoring the
externalities completely is not it
doesn't work out but you can sort of add
in some minor externalities and still
get
there's almost this critical thing right
because it's basically saying how
vehicles when I walked up yeah what's
going on is coming back to yeah exactly
so you don't have any such single car
no but that's also where you that's
right but also where so time-varying
thing well you know stuff goes into one
place in the morning and you know
accumulation affects about that yeah
that is really pricing where one target
a will have a reason to go back right
that might be good that might fix this
for free
yeah so in practice I think yes I'm
unclear if you can prove something
theoretical so we have some ideas how to
extend this partially to time varying
but um this right now the way you have
authorities do REM stations and vehicles
and each one states that when they
arrives a new station it states for some
exponential time but it's not sugar the
only external arrival if you have a user
price differently does not still a
Markov chain yeah so if I understand
what you're saying you're saying if
drivers were allowed to exit or join the
system when when I violated this
condition I should be okay
I think that's true no might take away
from the reward because you're to pay
this guy let go yeah so I don't say we
have proving it but if you ask me should
you implement something like this or
totally I mean Chris we should have done
this again I think this is the right way
of thinking about this problem there's
some natural reason why it should work
out but it's kind of pleasing that you
can show some
yeah quick question so you call it a
relaxation so why do you call it the
relaxation because it Jensen's
inequality okay because I don't know
what this gives studies so I'm just
saying now I'm gonna maximize over all
possible admission policies but then I
may not actually get the correct flows
so for example one such Q would be send
everything from I to J and nothing like
turn off everything else but then I
don't really have the supply to get this
bound so I'm sort of ignoring the fact
the availability constraint that was the
non convexity which but if you add the
circulation constraints that doesn't
change conveyances it doesn't change
convexity and it sort of prevents me
from doing these weird policies that's
that's sort of the intuition why but
that is the intuition why this is kind
of the right constraint to add if you
have that constraint to begin with
oh just even then at the top yeah so so
maybe another way of around this is you
could ask that okay are we missing
something but you can show that this is
straight there are instances where we
get exactly this bomb so I mean putting
all this together we can show there's a
bound of M over M plus N and this is
fundamental like there is a very simple
example where our policy does give em
over there where you can actually can
like construct the optimal policy and we
are off by this factor so it truly is a
relaxation I can write that offline but
we have fairly confident this technique
can't go further tunnels and and that's
what they out there the circulation
coaster they'll be the circulation so
with all of this we cannot beat em over
endless
if you don't buy into the stochastics
ignore the set of the short summary of
what we've done is that even though this
is a really messy looking logistical
problem there is there's sort of okay
what at least I think is a fairly
intuitive way of thinking about like
policies for this which are
approximately optimal and there is we
think you can extend it to certain more
complex settings so you can add
reservations that that won't turns out
to be fairly easy it works if you have
multiple objectives so if you want to do
something like maximize revenue subject
to a bound on blah that stuff turns out
to be like subject to a bound on welfare
that's still a convex program and
everything works out you can do this for
dispatch rebalancing combinations of
those just because it's so simple in
structure all of that works to an extent
we think there's some ways of extending
it to like pooling and reservations but
there we do know there are gaps and
we're kind of losing out a lot using
this technique well but it's still so a
pleasingly unified way of thinking about
the logistics so at least like a first
approximation to optimizing the
logistics of these systems and for me
the really big thing is where do we get
these parameters so where are we finding
out these demand rates and prices versus
so what I'll try to argue in the next 20
minutes or so is this is where I think
market mechanisms cover so what market
mechanisms are doing is they're not sort
of fundamentally making these systems
better you know in a certain way but but
there's of taking away the burden of
trying to learn and estimate these
parameters example for any move on I
mean any other questions about this part
okay so oddly enough I've actually done
the work on pricing before I did this so
this was work with Carlos to kill me on
a major Harley and the reason we got
really interested in tried chatting in
the first place was this was a chord by
Preston McAfee who is the chief
economist at Microsoft um this came out
in 2015 and what Preston micro fees are
essentially arguing for is that that
market design in some sense is gonna get
more and more important in pretty much
all walks of life as we move forward and
his feeling was that 2016 would be the
year when Silicon Valley recognized that
the great value of right change was the
marketplace not that it um some clear to
me if that's happened or not but I mean
uber and lyft definitely do have a lot
more sort of economists and econ CS
folks but and the reason we get really
excited about thinking about
ride-sharing is it's a it's kind of
unique amongst all marketplaces and that
the platform sets the price this is
really not true for pretty much any
other marketplace so if you think of say
Airbnb or Etsy or anything of that sort
any of these marketplaces they act as a
board like a message board where buyers
and sellers are negotiate pricing US
Cellular set prices and right sharing
somehow went around this with this bold
decision to just set prices and there
were right sharing forms which
experimented with letting drivers choose
their prices they don't exist in so in
some sense it feels like this is the
right model for action and in some sense
what we were intrigued by is why is this
the case of what is dynamic pricing and
the ability of the market to price in
these platforms what is it buying and
essentially our kind of short answer is
it's not buying something fundamentally
compared to static pricing but he's
buying this ability of an algorithm to
self calibrate to find the right
parameter settings without actually
learning the parameters so what do I
mean by this so so you guys kind of the
underlying conundrum that we had so if
you think about or if you just look at
the rates that the request rates within
certain Rd blocks of the sort of diagram
David was showing these are definitely
time varying but they're somewhat
predictable they vary in fairly
consistent ways so if you
at the data in the morning people are
trying to come from the suburbs into the
center if you look at it in the evening
they're going in the opposite direction
there is a kind of intuitive underlying
trends which exist in fairly persistent
fashions so so that the puzzle is in
some sense not that why not do dynamic
pricing but why not just have like a
schedule of rates why not say these are
the these are the rates you have for
different hours of the day and then just
keep it in place you're not going to
have people complaining at Ober for
doing search pricing etc it seems like
it solves everything we have all this
data why not do hourly prices and that's
sort of what I want to understand like
what is the difference between making
prices depend on the instantaneous state
versus making it just depend on what
happens over a few hours of time and I
use basically the same model as before
to try and understand this question but
the one the big simplification I'll do
then I'll just focus on a single region
so I'll focus on a single station and in
some sense I'll think of all other
stations as like the net effect of cars
coming from other stations as being sort
of averaged out into a flow of cars
you'll see this in a second but as
before I'll assume all the mean per amp
the system parameters stay the same so
the arrival rates stay the same and I
can still charge a price which is a
function of the number of vehicles in
the station at the moment I'm not
looking at the number of vehicles at
other stations just the instantaneous
number of stage vehicles in the current
station how many vehicles are there in
this equation I'm going to assume that
you want a fixed fraction of every
dollar spent this is not essential but
in some sense for there is the results
extend but they will become Messier if I
don't miss you and this the crucial
assumption is this one so as before I my
passengers are still myopic the students
react to the instantaneous quantities
but I'm going to think of the driver as
I start making decisions of whether or
not to work on the system based on a
sort of long-term sampling of the system
so think of it as I'm trying to decide
between working as a freelance and web
design or something versus working on
lyft or uber for a certain amount of
time what what I'm thinking of the
drivers as do
they they kind of try out the system for
a few days and see am I making enough
money or not is it worthwhile is it
worthwhile is is the sort of the cost
worth it in terms of doing this and once
they do this they make a decision do I
want to work for lists or do I not what
what time do I want to work where do I
wonder and what this means in terms of
the model is I still have a similar
birth-death process of cars at a station
as before so these are the number of
cars which I increasing and I'm seeing
the cars are increasing at some rate
lambda aggregates all the cars coming in
from outside and from other places um
but I've said these prices and in
particular what I've done here is I've
selected a threshold I have a low price
higher than the Thresher and a high
price lower than that so what it's going
to do is when there are lot of cars I
have a low price or some sort of trying
to push the system down and then when I
have very few cars I sort of I'm
deterring people from taking these cars
and push the number of cars back up so
that's what happens for the passengers
this is this this is what's new in this
model which is the way the driver thinks
about it is I'm thinking of there's this
a potential flow of drivers I think of
there's this potential population of
drivers who could join each one has some
reservation value there's there's some
magic number for which they're going to
work on the platform and they like have
this amazing simulator they simulate the
system and they figure out how much they
would earn if they joined the system and
then they decide whether to join so
they're making this decision based on
they have this reservation value they're
looking at the sort of long-term earning
from the platform and they're deciding
whether to join or not the problem of
course being is that this is sort of
inducing like an equilibrium system so
then the amount of money they earn and
the amount of time they spend on the
system will depend on who decides to
join the system what we want to
understand is what is the equilibrium of
this when we do dynamic pricing but any
questions about that so that that's the
question that I want to try and
understand um you could argue that okay
why is this fact that drivers look at a
long term figures valid um there's a
sense in which all the right
actually try and encourage drivers to do
this so they give these kind of weekly
summaries again from a few years back
but essentially what would lyft and uber
give is some sort of weekly summary of
how much money you made how much money
you would have made if you worked at
some other time at some other place etc
etcetera so you are sort of encouraging
the drivers to do this kind of what-if
analysis and decide what is best
so our driver costs not by me and I'm
sweeping that under the rug to lift and
over understand that I don't know
there's a relative question relative to
say transport companies they do have a
yeah yeah so the in some sense the put
the benefit and the weakness of the
market is you you don't care the market
is what the market is the drivers decide
whether it's worthwhile for them but
that's kind of skirting along the topic
but yeah yeah no I completely agree so
I'm assuming that yeah I'm sweeping that
under the rock okay so this is how the
equilibrium system that I've set up I'm
setting these prices which depend on the
number of drivers this leads to a
steady-state system steady state of this
queue the driver looks at the steady
state and says okay this is how much
money this is the early earning I'll get
this how much money I earn this is how
much time I spend on the platform they
then compared it to doing whatever else
they would have done and they decide is
it worthwhile fun I want to try and
understand what's the equilibrium models
this is messy enough that I mean we can
show existence and conditions for
uniqueness
there's no closed-form for this I mean
there's no hope of getting that but it's
one dimension so if I had just a single
price this is just a one-dimensional
problem I could just search for the
equilibrium that's what I've done here
and so there's a nice thing that's
happening is as I increase I just have a
single price the static pricing as they
increase that if the price is zero
drivers are not earning any money why
would they join as I increase the price
drivers are getting happier and happier
at this point what's happening is now
the passengers are upset at the price
and so the time between each riders blow
so the driver Singh okay I'm working for
three hours but I'm not getting enough
right when I get it right that I'd get a
lot of money but it's not worthwhile and
so even though I have not built
instability into the model the stability
of the queuing system itself is just
implicit in looking at before the
circulation it has to be stable and you
can play the same game but what I'm now
going to do is I'll take this number of
drivers or the arrival rate of drivers
and the arrival rate of passengers and
scale that so I'll just say what happens
if the system becomes ten times bigger
then I get a curve which looks like this
and I can keep doing this game what
happens if it gets 100 times bigger I
get another curve and it feels like it's
sort of approaching something and then
the nice thing is that you can actually
characterize exactly what it approaches
in the limit and it turns out that in
the limit the equilibrium goes or this
equilibrium rate of rides go converges
to the minimum of two functions one of
which only depends on supplying one of
which only depends on demand so if you
were an economist and you kind of looked
at it in this direction what you would
see is a demand supply curve gradient
assume a demand supply curve I sort of
assumed micro foundations and built up a
demand supply curve so this is the the
number the rate of rides that I get the
in the system divided by the scaling
parameter so the normalized rate of
rides but you could do this for revenue
or welfare you get something similar
now this is the single price so this is
okay so why do I like this this first
kind of the point at which we thought
okay this this model has some legs like
it makes sense it's not giving something
nonsensical so we can use this to start
asking what happens if you do dynamic
pricing so what if instead of a single
price I had two prices and this
threshold for when when to switch
between the prices oh okay you seem to
have removed the figures but you can
play the same game in terms of looking
at the scaling behavior and you can
again exactly characterize what happens
with dynamic pricing in the limit so
remove the scaling pictures but in the
limit what you can show is it's not
going to be the same as just having a
single price but interestingly the
maximum rate of rides that you can get
is identical under dynamic pricing or
static pricing so even if you sell
optimally choose these two prices and
this transition point the optimal thing
to do is actually to have a single price
which corresponds to the optimal static
price and under some conditions you can
prove this formally so assuming a
certain like the certain distribution as
is regular on the rate of rides for any
dynamic pricing policy with two prices
on a single threshold is less than equal
to that under the optimal static price
every time I give this talk or there's a
sense people feel that this is perhaps
obvious take a few seconds to convince
you that this is not an obvious but it's
not completely trivial so there is a
sense that if you're taking this limit
maybe there are no fluctuations in the
limits like maybe in the fluid limit
there is no randomness there's no
different there's just a fixed number of
drivers so I'm seeing a single price
actually that's not true so what
happening is because I'm also changing
the point at which I flip between the
prices what happens is in the limit
every time a passenger comes in this
sample from our iid distribution of cars
so example five cars 10 cars blah blah
blah and then there's a fixed parameter
which decides how much they have to pay
there's not obvious but you can show
that and there's also this this kind of
remarkably similar to their these are
similar results in revenue
the one raisin etc would say that under
certain limits
static prices are optimal but that is
actually also not true here so if you if
I remove this assumption like for
example if I have a mixture distribution
you can show that a dynamic price does
strictly better than a static price even
in the middle so this this the closest
parallel that we found to this in sort
of existing literature there's this
literature on kind of market
segmentation in large markets like when
is it beneficial to segment a market
into multiple parts or segment buyers
into two parts versus sort of not
segment them and then you kind of get
qualitatively similar phenomenon in some
sense what we are showing is under this
of queueing model you get similar
conditions as these market segmentation
problems but it's also a little
disappointing because I kind of promised
you that dynamic pricing is really
important and this seems to suggest that
it's not there is this amazing static
price in the sky which would have just
optimized everything I understand the
vertical axis here is the right rate yes
this is the rate of Rights this is the
revenue yeah so but but this is kind of
fairly robust to what you can look at
welfare and this of similar I should
have something I said the final kind of
expressing is that they react to my
claim is so that's true and that could
help but then the thought is perhaps
arrivals don't change that fast but
really I mean dynamic pricing is
reacting to instantaneous case it in
some sense like are they enough course
of course okay so what we're thinking
about it is yes if I'm I'm not going to
claim that these will hold as is if I
have changing arrival rates but but
there's still a question suppose we
don't have changing arrival rates can be
sure that it's doing something
interesting what is dynamic pricing
doing it's not this
there's another possibility which is for
a given arrival rate there's a fixed
price outstanding as you change there
are places changes yes I think whatever
think it's changing almost
instantaneously and so the dynamic
pricing tracks that okay definitely the
same is true and so maybe it's a mixture
and then how do you solve for this yep
then this sum look up table which says
it's a rival right vector is this then
impose this what uses this static price
right so that's what this would suggest
you should do my argument is the kind of
the big weakness and that is do I really
know that arrival rate example and one
way of formalizing this I could ask the
question okay
how does my performance change if I have
some uncertainty in this parameter so is
this prediction I made robust to knowing
this this arrival rate exactly versus
having some error that's kind of what we
did so we said okay so what if you had
like a demand shock so what if I didn't
know the exact demand but I knew it up
to like plus minus 10% so this would be
the optimal rate that you'd get the
optimal in this case rate of Rights if
you knew the exact quantities but what
I'm doing here is I'm assuming at some
point and then trying to just fix that
static price and see what performance
eye kit and what's happening here is
your price your performance is kind of
falls off a cliff if you do really badly
as soon as you have some uncertainty in
or in the direction does that make sense
so what I've done is I've said I'm
assuming there is a certain set of
parameters I solved for this amazing
optimal price I implemented but in
reality the parameters were slightly
perturbed and this is the optimal rate I
would have got if I knew the parameter
this is what I get if I just fix this
single thing now on the other hand what
I could do is I could say well maybe I I
know I have this uncertainty so I know
one within plus minus 10% so I know this
number Mew naught is anything between
3.6 and 4.4 and I can
use that to set up the two prices so I
can you know this is my pessimistic
price because it's like my optimistic
demand for car this is a pessimistic
demand forecast I set a high price um
and if you do that what you can show is
that like under dynamic pricing using
that policy you're actually very close
to this optimal solution particular
formally what you can show is the
performance under dynamic pricing is
always better than like a linear
approximation of this optimal model if I
select the set of break points draw a
linear approximation of this curve
dynamic pricing will always be above
that and I could do it with multiple
such points so I could say I have like
six prices which I arranged in some
order in some sense what it's doing is
its kind of getting this nice linear
approximation to this curve without
actually knowing the parameters and you
can formally show that this is true so
there is a kind of intrinsic robustness
which is built into dynamic pricing so
it does not need to know the parameters
exactly but because it can react to the
changes in some sense in under scaling
the changes happen fast enough that your
prices calibrate how much the drive was
responding to yeah so pressing this
always is changing supply so I think
that's not I mean that's definitely true
to an extent but I think that can't
happen fast enough so if there is like a
increase it's gonna take like 15 20
minutes for a driver to react to that
but a model that you started with your
driver is you go from state I to state J
essentially instantaneously as a model
may have God there's no hysteresis okay
yeah no that's right so I am NOT okay so
I'm not looking at that at all it could
run in services and supervision Aladdin
see if you
this right yeah I should I don't know
there's a survey particular proof
technique I use which I know will break
down there but which is not an excuse
for not having done but yeah every so
I'm not claiming this is the only effect
I am trying to convince you it's is
quite a surprising effect like we did
not expect it to be such a good
approximation and there is a very good
sir explanation as to what's going on
there there does seem to be a self
intrinsic robustness to these policies
which at least I feel is kind of the
stronger reason why they seem to work so
well they're not fundamentally better
but they have this inbuilt robustness
now is this something which I'm
validating using data no I'm pretty sure
if the drivers react to some extent so
one thing I did as soon as that drivers
I hit this but I I assume drivers exit
the system without looking at the price
just probabilistically I think if you
relax that and say they look at the
price and if it's high they stay that'll
be a second order effect but I mean I we
did some simulations for just that and
that was second order but yeah I agree
that something that's not there but okay
so that that's kind of what I was
suggesting that what I think the market
mechanisms are buying in these platforms
is not necessarily that they are better
than kind of static pricing but they
seem to sort of by this intrinsic robust
method if they buy this or lack of
sensitivity to like getting your
estimates wrong so um things Ramesh was
saying that he likes to quote it I think
that you can either trust your data
science team another you can trust and
I'm like racing we in some sense are
suggesting trusting dynamic pricing is
but completely I mean I'm not gonna
claim this answers everything but it's
sort of intriguing as to it's not the
usual narrative of what's going on in
these platform but it's I think a fairly
strong the strong suggestion has to
something of this sort is going
quick question sir the supply of drivers
you showed us earlier so given a static
price plan that entire price trajectory
will determine their supply of drivers
step made small the average under the
price trajectory so I set up the price
trajectory the system reaches some
equilibrium whatever I get under that
the drivers look at the average and
decide whether so they are reacting with
they're reacting to sort of the smooth
out resolution and that same response is
used for dynamic pricing as well same
responsiveness whatever and can you
reminds the dynamic prices price is a
function of instantaneous number of
vehicles in a region I look at on me the
five vehicles H I will do something of
the pen write charge of Lawrence so if
you have a large network with many
locations this could be a function with
a very high dimensional domain yeah so
um instantaneous price only of your new
mode so you you ignore other
neighborhoods you only look at your new
board it's a local instantaneous so it
is just one dimension she don't care
where the cost go through when you send
them I know I'd like to argue in a weak
sense that the two parts somehow argue
that he should decouple them but yeah in
this model we don't care so as far as I
know you know live to provide some kind
of incentives to the graduates I mean so
that the drivers you know are well
so how does all that play out into this
I mean I have no idea um that's why I
didn't yeah I mean I could try making up
stories but I don't have a very clear
answer to that so yeah so what happens
to other driver incentives how do they
sort of play into this it's unclear if
you talk to an economist that usually
suggests that there's a sense in which
you shouldn't even have those incentives
the right thing to do would be
completely insulate the drivers from
these marketplace dynamics it's not
being done and it's a really interesting
question as to what like how these
different pieces mesh together I mean I
think this is a very interesting set of
questions just the drive incentives it's
a good segue to come to what I think are
the interesting question so just maybe
five minutes so so what I saw showed up
to now was we have these models which I
think are good models for these systems
they set up fairly non-trivial problems
about like solving the logistics and the
pricing but but we have now some handle
on how to do it in certain approximate
senses and you seem to get certain
strong signals as to why these pricing
mechanisms and these are simple like
flow models seem to work so so that's
kind of the state of things as they are
so one question I think this is what
they were posed pointing out um what do
we get if we switch from state
independent to state dependent so as I
was saying we kind of have a counter
example which shows you cannot improve
on our result and that that counter
example actually works even if you do
state um yeah I think then take that
back but there is a very strong sense in
which we have counter examples which
show you cannot even if you did state
dependent you can't get better than this
M over m plus n compared to this convex
relaxation like the relaxation is just
too weak in certain regimes and this is
sort of okay for those of you who seem
like these models and revenue management
like their certain regimes where you get
like a square root t regret or in bandit
problems a certain other regimes where
you do much better we solve similar
phenomena which happens here but it
turns out for just the dispatch problem
under
a certain beaker assumption called
complete resource pooling you can
improve the result and sure that you can
get the sub optimality to actually decay
exponentially them so instead of one
plus n over m you can get something like
1 plus a constant times e to the minus n
to the minus theta M but I mean we don't
know anything about the constants we
just know this in what's called the
large deviation sense that you can show
there's an optimal policy the optimal
policy is state dependent it's actually
fairly non trivial to even construct
what it is so this was joint work with
from your chair and your second area at
Columbia but I mean we could show what
the optimal policy is that it looks
something like what's called a shifted
max weight policy but you can prove that
it gets exponential decay so initially
this policy may be better but in in sort
of a large system that policy will be
better
I've not dealt at all with bursty
arrivals like all my models at persona
rivals it's a very natural question what
happens if you have burst and this is I
think a really meaningful question like
I would argue this is the first-order
effect in any of these systems just
because of things like train stations or
games getting over to concerts or things
like that and just like what are the
right policies for bursty arrivals I
don't have a great idea I think that's
interesting problem to look at non
stationary as well although I think I
think bursty sort of the right so the
point at which you will get interesting
first order effects um one other
question ok can be served yes that's one
of the cases with data science team they
have something they go like we did
something where the obsolete data taxi
they there's some events in Jacob Javits
Center so if I give business tomorrow
rice was for your final rice in I expect
to get roughly far right now for a
certainty
long time when the event ends up and
finishes and we found that this was true
not just there were some other cities
nowhere data so especially like you went
taste no idly and if I get what you're
saying is suggesting that you should
handle these outside the system in some
sense like you sure you use data as well
yeah you can use data predict this and
then somehow it maybe give maybe do
reservations in advance to a smooth in
the circle yeah so that's what I think
is the interesting that that dynamic
pricing alone is the wrong way to target
that you need an additional serve lever
to target that what is that lever I mean
I start checking like rules that you
chain will arrive in like you're driving
in the chain you know when you like
you're almost there it's not so I do
things that live to those reservations
now and so you can do advanced
reservations you can say I am I think
I'll arrive in 10 minutes blah blah blah
I'm so reserved for that which I think
is the right way to go about it but yeah
just something that I feel the
interesting mechanism design questions
there with that oh and then that sort of
segues into this like how do we kind of
use these tools to think about
reservation I think that's a really
interesting is the same thing David sort
of brought up getting reservation
mechanism they it feels somewhat
old-school but like they that it's
coming back it's going to be back in
fashion like lift has this interesting
thing where I correct me if you still
have it where you can reserve your
morning commute and the idea is that you
can sort of do this commute with someone
else and so reserve with the previous
night is this right or am I making this
up okay yeah you tried it and it didn't
work okay so that's even more reason why
we should be thinking about these
problems see it clearly doesn't work
exactly as we would expect so but I
think reservation mechanisms were really
interesting
but you can definitely say that in the
city you live in it doesn't it the guy
is a bad example to think about scaling
and systems below these two drivers even
eclipses consists of drivers because the
population of the town is thirty
thousand
everything is ten minutes of each other
so yeah there's no there's no intrinsic
scaling demands of a exceeds supply and
there's no reservation they just don't
have reservation by a longshot and
that's your destiny yeah yeah I mean not
the normal way around um right pooling
is one thing which I think is really
fascinating just from a kind of
combinatorial optimization perspective
this idea of sort of combining these
rides and some optimal way um this is
something like if you ask me what's like
the one problem I'd really like to work
on I think even when I stopped working
on this project like I always thought
ride pooling was the interesting one um
it does feel like it's having a huge
effect like I get cheaper rides for sure
and if you take cliff kind of if you
haven't tried lyft line over pool
there's a market difference in the ride
um it feels anecdotally that the the
fraction of people getting matched up is
also increasing there it feels like a
win-win for everyone you get cheaper
rides there's less pollution but yeah
but but they're just nice problems and
thinking about that we've been thinking
a little about it but again there's not
much know if I can we go beyond this
just talk about like maybe a few more
things which I think are interesting and
hopefully we can work on over the summer
over the semester so one is the impact
of platform computation now this is the
problem which in some sense only the
academics would care about the
platform's care about it but will they
really try to work and some formal way
on this I don't there are some interests
but this is something which I think is
really important not just from a game
theory point of view in terms of just
competition between two
from a duopoly model but just what's the
effect on society of having two
competing platforms providing the same
service so we started thinking a little
bit about this so this was joint work
with the Oceania so he's a actually
undergraduate student that or master
student at the Ecole Polytechnique and
could be examine her son and I kick so
what we were looking at is a very
simplified model so so similar to the
model but have we been looking at but
what I want to understand is what's the
cost of having of doing this
optimization and ready central so what
do I mean I'm imagining a world where
there's either a single platform so the
Singapore government controls all of
ride-sharing versus their two platforms
which are operating and I'm thinking of
these two platforms they're not
competing with each other they've just
completely partitioned the space so
people people who are younger choose
lifts people who are older and richer
chose uber or make up your own stories
but in some sense the world has got
partitioned into lift users and
employees and what I want to understand
it and what each of these platforms
the only control lever they're using is
just rebalance their rebalancing the
empty vehicles and they try to do this
as best as possible to try and minimize
cost while serving as many people as
possible what we wanted to understand
was like what's the price of fragmenting
the market into two pieces so what's the
price that we incur when I have us when
I go from a single platform to sort of
solving two separate optimization
problems when the demand is getting
partition but it's sort of getting
randomly partition so what's the
difference in some sense there is this
one convex program we're solving what
happens to this problem when we split it
into two convex programs with random
inputs you serve that sine driver
doesn't work yeah so yeah so the way we
were thinking about it is this is the
future with autonomous vehicles both
firms have their own forms of autonomous
vehicles everyone has is in team lift or
team uber you've made your decision
what's happening so maybe we should let
them finish
I was trying it and then have questions
yeah yeah okay but I'm like one mostly
so okay what happens here it's somewhat
surprising so what it turns out is you
actually get a phase transition so it
turns out that depending on what the
underlying demand is if the underlying
demand is has a certain structure then
you actually when you scale up the
demand your rates your sub optimality
decays to zero whereas in some other
regimes your sub optimality actually
goes to infinity and the interesting
thing is this is in some sense not
academic if you look at the New York
City data and sort of apply our
criterion on that you actually see this
regime show up in certain hours of the
day so you get roughly 10% of like
blocks of time when the system appears
to be in this state so I'll be imagining
the New York City data is being the
centralized platform and then trying to
think of what happens when it gets split
into two pieces and you do it seems like
you could get these effects so what we I
mean in some extent I'm not claiming
this exists or that we do think this
exists to some say in to some extent but
it's also the higher level point being
that you can get really interesting
effects in these problems just because
of the underlying combinatorial nature
so even something as simple as what
happens when you have two platforms
competing is not an obvious answer so
there's a few of the questions I cannot
put these up which I think I was
thinking about so one of them is this
thing I've been inside of hang upon what
is the value of information like how
much do we buy from forecasting versus
how much do we buy from having
algorithms which in some sense self
calculator um there is some really
really nice work recently I'm thinking
about this for the what's called the
switch scheduling model where you don't
need there's a certain algorithm which
we've known for a long time this thing
called max speed which you can prove
kind of does the self calibration of a
very very strong way um so it's kind of
optimal in a very strong sense and I'm
kind of intrigued by can we come up with
other algorithms which do this so other
algorithms for this problem which sort
of
quickly self calibrate when the
parameters change and can we prove
something formally about how fast they
do this I think this is a really
important question and I mean it's not
clear what's the right way to attack it
but in some sense it's it's less about
how does right change affect public
transit but more how can it sort of help
on the transit so there is a sense that
there are inefficiencies in public
transit so in particular things like the
last mile problem and there it feels
like it's not obvious at least that
whether when you combine the two if it's
like submodular super do you get
benefits from combining the two or does
it hurt each other in equilibrium but
it's clear that the policy is much
change must change so at the moment the
two don't talk to each other but what
what is the right sense for the two to
be talking to each other can we sort of
start answering that and again this is
something where I feel academia may move
first before the platform's really think
about this this is kind of even further
out but just like there are a lot of
these articles now but like what is the
role of like a freelance worker in
society in general like my way of
framing this in the context of
ride-sharing is what is the right mix of
like people that you employ to drive
freelancers and and coming up soon like
autonomous vehicles like should you have
a completely autonomous service now
where what happens to all these people
who are earning money should you do you
introduce them in small numbers how do
they work with each other again
something where there's going to be some
amount of modeling but but I think we
are at a point where we can start
thinking about some of these so I hope
to do that over the semester sorry for
running late
[Applause]
the impression that fashion competition
that in China it's so it's very
different from the competition that you
show yeah so I'm really looking at
fragmentation so I'm sort of saying so I
would like to believe that having kind
of tautologically having choice is good
for the consumers before the driver so
it does feel like it's better for us to
have both these services and perhaps
even more of this speculation why yes I
mean I think if you start looking at if
I now sort of building things like
people choose which services giving a
lower price you could you can maybe come
up with fairly simple models where okay
X started off with at a better position
initially in terms of maybe cash
reserves and so they could drive the
other company out before school I
sincerely hope not um everyone I switch
to the market function around I don't
know I guess the one thought would be
there are others similar I mean this
seems similar to things like the
airplane networks I mean do to say
airplane networks like again you could
have had one company take over or say
rental cars in some sense it hasn't
happened so money and I imagine left is
also not making money
[Laughter]
oh this time we can't push them to
answer this question but I know so I
mean I think it's a it's a good question
there's a sense that I don't think I can
say something useful about that yet but
perhaps in these limited context is you
had the number of vehicles fixed or
something so if the platform can control
the number of vehicles with an increase
of decreases the revenue to the platform
go up or down so that depends on how you
engineer like how much the driver gets
fixed
yeah so with so I mean I can give you an
answer under this model but but I am
hiding the fact that like this is not
the optimal spray okay um I think it
should go up but because so the
intuitive argument would be I can always
throw out certain drivers by making it
so I should always in some sense be able
to simulate a more restricted system
given more resources so if I do it
optimally it feels weird that it won't
go up
but no no that's what so that's yeah
yeah so under this model what would
happen um I don't know can I can I make
sure that we've depends on the shape of
the supply curve yeah it must depend on
the shape of the supply curve but what
fraction of these populations is hard
comes right there right so pushing up
the price when we have to put the put up
in multiplier to get rid of some people
how high does the first chance of that
fuzzy champions
yeah so monopolies you expect reduce
service or greater service or what I
don't know off the top of my head okay
so I think the right yeah so I think the
right way of formulating would be what
is the parameter of these curves which
controls this compared to static um I
genuinely haven't thought about that
yeah that's right okay maybe given that
your first time we can take other
questions offline I'm sure
sitting around for next period so thank
you very much